es posible que a usted o a un ser
querido le hayan diagnosticado
linfoma este video le ayudará a entender
algunas de las opciones de tratamiento
disponibles el linfoma es un tipo de
cáncer que comienza en el sistema
linfático en el tejido linfático el
linfoma se origina en ciertos tipos de
glóbulos blancos denominados
linfocitos en el caso del linfoma los
linfocitos crecen y se aplican lo cual
da lugar a la producción de muchas
células anormales que no funcionan como
es debido los dos tipos principales de
linfoma son el linfoma de hotchkin y el
linfoma no
hotchkin su médico establecerá un plan
específico para usted a fin de tratar el
linfoma se basará en el tipo de linfoma
el estadio los síntomas la edad el
estado general de salud y otros factores
las opciones de tratamiento pueden
incluir una o más de las siguientes
opciones
quimioterapia
radioterapia terapia dirigida
inmunoterapia y transplante de células
madre por lo general la quimioterapia se
inyecta en una vena debajo de la piel o
se toma por vía oral a través de una
píldora luego la quimioterapia ingresa
al torrente sanguíneo para alcanzar y
destruir las células
cancerosas otra opción de tratamiento es
la radioterapia utiliza Rayos de alta
energía para eliminar las células
cancerosas o evitar que se desarrollen
el área objetivo de la radiación varía
según el estadio y el tipo de
linfoma el tipo de radioterapia
utilizada para el linfoma es la
radiación
externa utiliza una máquina que apunta
Rayos de radiación cuidadosamente
enfocados al cáncer desde el exterior
del
cuerpo los medicamentos empleados en la
terapia dirigida actúan sobre objetivos
específ íos o marcadores en las células
cancerosas dado que las células
cancerosas pueden tener más de estos
marcadores que las células normales es
posible que los medicamentos de la
terapia dirigida afecten más a las
células cancerosas que a las células
normales cuando los medicamentos de la
terapia dirigida se adhieren a los
marcadores en las células cancerosas
dichas células podrían dejar de
desarrollarse y dividirse esto también
puede dar lugar a la muerte
celular la inmunoterapia puede ayudar al
sistema inmunológico a combatir el
linfoma por ejemplo los an cuerpos
monoclonales son versiones artificiales
de las proteínas que produce el sistema
inmunológico para combatir las
infecciones los anticuerpos monoclonales
se pueden diseñar para atacar objetivos
específicos tales como los marcadores de
las células de
linfoma cuando se unen a las células
inmunitarias los anticuerpos
monoclonales permiten reconocer y
destruir las células de
linfoma un transplante de células madre
permite reemplazar las células madre
formadoras de sangre que fueron dañadas
o destruidas durante el tratamiento
contra el cáncer ya sea con sus propias
células madre o las de un donante sano
en primer lugar se toman células madre
sanas ya sea de usted mismo o de un
donante luego las células madres se
almacenan Mientras usted recibe
tratamiento para el cáncer como la
quimioterapia o la radiación a fin de
destruir todas las células sanguíneas
Una vez que se completan estos
tratamientos las células madre sanas se
traspasan a la sangre a través de una
vía intravenosa o
IB en el cuerpo estas células madres
formadoras de sangre ofrecen un
suministro saludable de futuras células
sanguíneas el médico puede recetarle una
combinación de los tratamientos que
hemos mencionado u opciones de otros
tratamientos al enfrentarse a un
diagnóstico de linfoma continúe hablando
con su médico y con su equipo de
atención médica del
cáncer
i